Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 115, die 115. Folge. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle da draußen an den Hörgeräten und ich bin hier an dieser kleinen Podcast- Wochenend-Tour, die ich gemacht habe, jetzt an meiner letzten Station angekommen und befinde mich in Großumstadt, in der Nähe von Darmstadt. Bin zwar hier mit Bahn und Bus gefahren, doch das Thema wird heute auf was ganz anderes gelenkt, nämlich auf das Fahrrad. Allerdings geht es weniger um die Fahrräder als solche, sondern um kleine elektronische Helfer, die man vielleicht beim Fahrradfahren gerne dabei hätte. Genauer gesagt geht es um das Projekt OpenBICO und darüber Auskunft geben kann vor allem Peer Georgi. Hallo Peer.
Hallo.
Denn du bist maßgeblich an diesem Projekt beteiligt, hast es losgetreten und ja, darüber wollen wir heute reden. Ja, vielleicht mal so in einem Satz. OpenBICO ist ein?
OpenBICO steht für Open Bicycle Computer. Es ist ein mobiles Gerät, was beim Fahrradfahren Einsatz finden soll. Also sprich im herkömmlichen Sinn ein Fahrradcomputer mit ein paar mehr Features, die man so braucht beim Fahrradfahren.
Genau, also ein digitaler Begleiter, so ein kleines Helferlein, ein Gerät, was jetzt hier auch auf dem Tisch liegt und so ein bisschen aus der Ferne, na ja, wenn es nicht so dick und eckig wäre, an ein kleines iPhone erinnern könnte, sprich der große Teil dieses Gerätes wird von einem Bildschirm eingenommen, ansonsten keine offensichtlichen Tasten oder Knöpfe, dafür aber ein paar Eingänge. Darüber werden wir auch gleich im Detail mal reden. Aber was mich zunächst einmal interessieren würde, ist, was so dein persönlicher Hintergrund eigentlich ist und was dich dann letzten Endes auf diese Idee gebracht hat, das zu machen.
Gut, grundsätzlich ist es so, dass ich mich seit recht langer Zeit mit der Entwicklung von Software und Hardware beschäftige und nebenbei auch Fahrradfahrer, denn man muss sich ein bisschen bewegen. Im Übrigen ist das Fahrrad halt das ideale Fortbewegungsmittel für kurze Strecken und ja, die Inspiration kam eigentlich durch die Tatsache, dass viele Fahrradcomputer, die man derzeit so benutzen kann, einfach immer dann nicht funktionieren, wenn man sie eigentlich braucht. Das heißt, die Batterien sind beispielsweise leer oder sie erfüllen einfach die Anforderungen nicht, die man so hat oder die ich so hatte.
Was gibt es denn eigentlich so auf der Markt?
Es gibt schon Fahrradcomputer, die nicht so groß und eckig sind, also die zum Beispiel kleiner sind und ein kleines Display haben und dementsprechend teilweise schwer abzulesen sind und ja, also es gibt, das ist das, was ich so kenne, alle sind alle gemein, allen gemein ist, dass sie mit Batterien betrieben werden. Das heißt, sie brauchen halt ständig Maintenance, man muss sie also warten, öffnen, abmachen, also man hat teilweise wirklich Ärger damit. Gut, dann gibt es natürlich die anderen Probleme, die man also hat durch die Geschwindigkeitsabnehmer, die man installieren muss und ja, das ist also nichtsdestotrotz gibt es durchaus Profi-Geräte, die vielleicht für den Rennsport geeignet sind oder vielleicht sogar im Moment besser geeignet sind als der BICO, da sie also wirklich kleiner sind und aus anderen Gründen vielleicht auch, aber es gibt eben Merkmale, die allen derzeit verfügbaren Fahrradcomputern einfach fehlen, die der BICO dann eben leisten soll.
Was sind denn das so für Sachen, die dir bei den anderen Geräten fehlen?
Zum Beispiel die Widderabe von Musik oder vielleicht von Texten oder Podcasts, wie wir jetzt einhören oder vielleicht die Information, wo ich gerade bin, also sprich eine schicke Kratendarstellung oder eine präzise Geschwindigkeitsaufzeichnung. Das heißt also sprich, wie schnell fahre ich wirklich, nicht in zweisekundlichen Updates zu wissen, wie schnell man ungefähr ist, sondern wie schnell ist man genau. Das ist einfach in Bezug auf Logging ganz interessant oder auch für Training beim Fahrradfahren oder vielleicht auch beim Erkunden neuer Strecken, also OpenStreetMap wäre dann ein Thema, um einfach neue Strecken abzufahren und so viele Details wie möglich über die abgefahrene Strecke einfach aufzunehmen.
Das heißt, du hast eigentlich den typischen, ich sag mal, den Geek-Nerd-Ansatz. Da muss doch eigentlich noch mehr gehen, so mit der Kenntnis der Technologie, was sich heutzutage alles theoretisch in so ein Gerät integrieren lässt und willst dich sozusagen auch mal aufs Machbare konzentrieren. Andererseits gibt es natürlich auch so die Abwägung, dass nicht alles, was geht, auch wirklich immer sinnvoll ist.
Genau, da muss man sich natürlich auch beschränken, oder? So ist es also. Der BICO hat ganz klare Ziele, die er erreichen soll. Ein typisches Beispiel, eine ganz interessante Analogie ist ja das mobile Telefon, also das Handy im allgemeinen Sinne, die ja mittlerweile auch schon ganz viel können. Also sie können mittlerweile auch sagen, wo man ist und vieles mehr. Man kann damit kommunizieren. Das ist zum Beispiel was, was der BICO nur begrenzt erfüllen soll. Einfach, er hat einfach andere Ziele. Also das Ziel ist nicht, alles in alles derzeit machbare in ein Gerät zu konzentrieren, sondern wirklich das, was man braucht. Das soll auch funktionieren unterwegs, unter allen Umständen und überall. Das heißt Unabhängigkeit ist ein ganz wesentlicher Punkt. Unabhängigkeit sowohl von irgendwelchen Netzen, von Mobilfunknetzen, als auch Unabhängigkeit von Energiequellen, also sprich Batterien. Und unter Ermittlung dieser Tatsachen will man trotzdem sehen, wo man ist und man möchte trotzdem ein großes Display haben und man möchte vielleicht Musik hören, die man sich mitgebracht hat oder sich Karten anschauen und man möchte Streckendaten aufnehmen.
Das heißt, diese GPS-Funktionalität, davon reden wir ja, ist auch schon ein integraler Bestandteil bei deinen Überlegungen gewesen.
Genau, also es ging am ersten Wurf weniger um zu sehen, wo man ist, sondern eher um Logging. Allerdings ist natürlich die Tatsache, dass wir jetzt ein schönes großes Display haben, die lädt natürlich dazu ein, dass man noch Karten darstellen und visualisieren möchte. Ein anderer Punkt ist natürlich auch Tracking, das heißt, man fährt vielleicht bekannte Strecken ab. Das ist also auch was, was es so in der Form zumindest noch nicht als fester Bestandteil des Fahrrads gibt. Also der BICO ist gebaut, um wirklich mit dem Fahrrad mehr oder weniger verheiratet zu sein. Das heißt, er ist zwar schon abnehmbar, aber soll im Laufe seines Lebens eigentlich nicht ständig hin und her transportiert werden, also abgenommen werden, sondern er gehört einfach zum Fahrrad, so wie die Avionik von einem Audi auch in einem Audi bleibt und nicht immer wieder rausgenommen wird, wenn man das Auto verlässt.
Der Bicycle Computer, aber der heißt ja nicht BICO, sondern er heißt ja OBICO oder OpenBICO. Was ist denn der Open-Teil an dieser Geschichte?
So, also die Entwicklung des Open Bicycle Computers umfasst ja verschiedene Bestandteile, also da gibt es zum einen die Hardware, also sprich alle elektronischen Bestandteile, die dazu führen, dass man nachher wirklich was sieht auf dem Display und überhaupt ein Display hat. Dann gibt es natürlich die Entwicklung des Gehäuses und es gibt natürlich auch die Entwicklung der Software. Das sind also diese drei integralen Dinge, die wir bis jetzt alle zum Prototypen-Stadium gebracht haben und Ziel soll es auf jeden Fall sein, die Software frei zu machen. Das heißt, die Software wird in Form von Download zur Verfügung stehen, sodass also jeder, dem also eine Anwendung einfällt, die man mit einem mobilen Computer machen kann, dass der die auch implementieren kann. Das heißt, es wird offene Apis geben und auch Dokumentation, die es einem versierten Entwickler erlauben, neues Software zu entwickeln. So ansonsten die Hardware wird in Form von Schaltplänen offengelegt. Das heißt also jeder kann sich die genaue Funktionalität des Systems anschauen bzw. studieren. Das ist einfach auch notwendig, damit jemand, der neue Software machen will, auch alle möglichen Dokumentationen dazu findet.
Wie ist das dann jeweils lizenziert? Hast du dich da schon festgelegt?
Die genaue Lizenz steht noch nicht fest. Für uns steht eigentlich nur fest, dass es die Möglichkeit geben wird, für den Anwender diese Daten noch einzusehen. Also es ist wahrscheinlich was GPL-ähnliches, wobei man natürlich, wir stehen jetzt natürlich vor dem Problem, es handelt sich auch um Hardware, das heißt, Hardware muss auch in irgendeiner Form, was wir also nicht wollen, um es gleich von und weg zu sagen, ist irgendjemand, der jetzt sowas kommerziell herstellen will, das einfach vor die Füße zu legen, damit er das einfach dann nachbaut und damit Geld verdient und vielleicht dann wieder Informationen weglässt. Wir wollen also wirklich dieses Gerät, so wie es ist, zur Verfügung stellen, auch für den Entwickler, dass er es ja also dort ansetzen kann, was wir eben dokumentiert haben. So und die genaue Lizenz, wie das jetzt bei Hardware aussieht, da sind wir einfach noch nicht genügend informiert. Vielleicht gibt es ja den ein oder anderen Hörer, der uns dazu Hinweise geben kann.
Ja, das ist natürlich vor allem erstmal eine Philosophiefrage. Wenn man es jetzt wirklich komplett offen macht, dann bietet sich natürlich so eine Creative-Commons-Lizenz an. Das ist mal die Frage mit so einer Einschränkung der Kommerzialität, wobei das dann natürlich immer sehr schwierig ist, das zu bewerten.
Zumal ein gewisser Grad an Kommerzialität wahrscheinlich auch nicht ausgeschlossen werden kann, weil die Hardware muss ja gebaut werden. Und derjenige, der das Gerät benutzt, muss es natürlich auch erwerben. Also muss es in irgendeiner Form... Also er kann es wahrscheinlich nicht von einer Pico auf selbst zusammenlöten, weil einfach die Strukturen handy-ähnlich sind. Das heißt, wir verwenden auch sogenannte BGA's, also Schaltkreise, die man mit normalen Lötkäumen nicht löten kann.
Das sind diese Boil-Grid-Arrays.
Die haben die Anschlüsse auf der Unterseite. Das stellt jetzt den selbstinversierten Löter und erstmal verunlösbare Probleme. Das heißt, man braucht jemanden, der einem das bestückt, denn die Geräte, die man zum bestücken braucht, sind also sehr teuer, liegen jenseits der 20.000 Euro-Grenze, was den einfachen Nachbau erstmal auf die Weise verhindert. Was aber denkbar ist, ist, dass wir Komponenten davon anbieten können, die sagen wir mal fertig produziert und vielleicht auch getestet sind. Der Test ist also auch ein ganz wesentlicher Knackpunkt, wenn man die Schaltung, also die Hardware des Gerätes betrachtet. Wie gesagt, ist die von der Komplexität ungefähr handy gleich. Also abgesehen davon, dass wir kein GSM-Modul haben, ist es aber von den Strukturen her nicht wesentlich anders und dementsprechend muss man die Hardware auch testen. Also der Test ist ein ganz wesentlicher Punkt auch, der das Ganze kompliziert macht und den selbstinvasierten Elektroniker vielleicht erstmal schon vor Probleme stellt und diesen Test würden wir natürlich auch machen. Das heißt, die genaue Art und Weise, wie wir die Hardware vertreiben, ist noch nicht klar, aber das werden wir definitiv auch lösen.
Ja, das war jetzt schon eine ganze Menge Sachen, da wollen wir jetzt mal so ein bisschen im Einzelnen drauf eingehen. Also ich denke, das Anwendungsszenario, das Grobe an sich, ist klar. Also das Ding, also das hat, muss man dazu sagen, extrem stabiles Gehäuse, das sieht so ein bisschen aus wie so ein neuer McIntosh, irgendwie so ein Alugehäuse aus einem, aus einem Guss oder sagen wir mal, gefräst ist es wahrscheinlich, nämlich an.
Genau.
Und das verschraubt man dann mit so einer Klammer direkt fest mit dem Fahrrad. Genau, das soll in der Mitte des Lenkers drohen, wie man das auch erwarten würde.
Das sind zwei Komponenten, also der Socke wird direkt mit dem Fahrrad verbunden, entweder direkt am Lenker oder auch an dem Lenkerknochen, der also in der Mitte ist, wobei man den wahrscheinlich auch woanders befestigen kann und das Gerät selbst wird in den Sockel hineingeschoben. Das ist also eine recht massive Schienenverbindung und wird dann mit einem Knauf arretiert. Also das hört sich jetzt alles sehr robust an. Das ist es auch, aber es sieht trotzdem smart aus. Also es ist alles Folge, Folge, gefriestes Aluminium, das ist eigentlich alles vom Feinsten.
Ist das teuer, so was, das Gehäuse?
Das ist recht teuer. Bis jetzt haben die, also gut, wir müssen jetzt dazu sagen, wir haben also jetzt den Prototyp oder mehrere Prototypen und man kann ganz klar sagen, ja, das ist teuer. Also die Entwicklung ist teuer und auch die Herstellung ist im Moment extrem teuer. Also das ist nichts, was man jetzt irgendwie mit einem normalen Handy in der Form vergleichen kann, was die Kosten angehen. Das liegt einfach daran, dass wir jetzt nur Einzelstücke machen und dass wir ja das Problem des Prototypings auch haben. Also wir haben im Moment recht wenige Stück, recht kleine Stückzahlen und deshalb ist sowas teuer im Moment. Also das muss man jetzt sagen.
Das meine ich jetzt, aber das ist ja klar, das wäre es wahrscheinlich auch, wenn es alles Plastik wäre, aber es ist ja im Prinzip euer, also eure Intention ist, auch am Ende was Stabiles zu haben. Also sozusagen diese feste Basis im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes ist auch Teil des Konzeptes.
Ganz genau, also das ist ein wesentlicher Punkt, der den BICO, sagen wir mal, allein stellt gegenüber anderen mobilen Geräten, die wir jetzt im Moment so haben. Also vielleicht das G-Phone, als mal ein Beispiel zu nennen, das ist natürlich ein absolutes smartes Gerät, toll, aber es ist eben nicht outdoor-tauglich, also das heißt, es darf nicht nass werden und es darf nicht erschüttert werden und so weiter.
Also G-Phone, du meinst das G1, das Google-Handy.
Genau, oder auch andere Handys, also das soll keine Abwertung des Google-Handys sein, das gilt einfach für alle mobilen Devices, die wir im Moment so haben. Alle Handhelds sind wirklich mehr oder weniger filigran, also das heißt, sie dürfen einfach nicht nass werden und so weiter. So und das ist beim BICO anders, der BICO ist einfach absolut massiv und absolut robust und soll den harten Anforderungen beim Fahrradfahren einfach auch gewachsen sein und man soll sich darüber beim Fahren nicht Gedanken machen müssen.
Okay, schauen wir noch mal, was das Gerät jetzt wirklich ausmacht. Also ich habe ja schon gesagt, so an der Frontseite ist so ein großer Bildschirm. Was gibt es denn sonst noch so für Körperöffnungen, in die man da reinschauen kann?
Genau, also zum Beispiel, also bei was jetzt die Körperöffnung betrifft, haben wir also ein SD-Card-Slot für MicroSD-Karten, wir haben einen USB-Anschluss und wir haben nach unten hin Federkontaktstellen, die also zum Sockel die Verbindung aufnehmen. Dort lässt sich der Dynamo verbinden, also beispielsweise der Namendynamo, den man heutzutage immer häufiger findet an Fahrrädern und Lenkertasten. Das ist auch ein ganz wesentlicher Punkt. Die Bedienung des Gerätes bei der Fahrt soll also nicht dadurch stattfinden, dass man die Hand vom Lenker nehmen muss und vielleicht auf irgendwelchen Touchscreens ummachen muss, sondern das geht also wirklich so. Das oberste Ziel oder ein Designziel ist, dass die Hand beim Lenker verbleibt und man direkt am Lenker das Gerät steuern kann. Man kann sich das so vorstellen, dass rechts und links am Lenker Tasten sind oder Hebel sind, die dann dazu führen, durch die Menüsstruktur zu navigieren oder eben auch einfache Sachen zu erledigen wie Vorspulen, Zurückspulen oder vielleicht rein- oder rauszoomen oder solche Dinge. Das sind jetzt die offensichtlichen Features, was ein ganz wesentliches Merkmal an dem Gerät ist. Es lässt sich durch den Dynamo versorgen, mit Stromversorgung. Das ist so, dass aktuelle Dynamos durchaus in der Lage sind, auch kleine Rechner zu versorgen. Das ist also ein Punkt, der zur Unabhängigkeit des Gerätes beiträgt. Wir müssen dieses Gerät nicht unbedingt stationär laden, sondern wir können, indem wir einfach ein bisschen schneller fahren oder ganz normal Fahrrad fahren, das Gerät einfach durch unsere eigene Körperkraft mit Stromversorgung.
Kann es dabei auch laden oder wird es nur betrieben?
Genau, das ist ein Punkt, der im Moment... Also die jetzige Aussage ist ja, wir können laden, allerdings erst ab einer bestimmten Geschwindigkeit und die Geschwindigkeit hängt natürlich vom Fahrrad ab und auch vom Dynamo ab. Man kann sich vielleicht dahingehend orientieren, so ab 15, 20 kmh, also bei zügiger Fahrt lässt sich das Gerät dadurch auch laden. Allerdings ist es jetzt schwierig, Aussagen zu machen, wie lange man muss, damit es vollgeladen ist. Es geht eigentlich nur darum, der Akku ist überhaupt erst mal nur deshalb drin, dass das Gerät nicht ausgeht bei einer roten Ampel. Also der Akku hat reine Stützfunktion. Das Ziel bei dem Akku ist nicht, das Gerät 5 Stunden mit Strom zu versorgen, sondern also wirklich nur kurze Pausen zu überbrücken und für eine stabile Operation zu sorgen.
Und wenn man stehen bleibt?
Wenn man stehen bleibt, übernimmt transparent der Akku die Stromversorgung. Und den letztendlichen Akkutyp, der steht noch nicht fest. Im Moment ist es so, dass das Gerät gut und gerne 1,5 bis 2 Stunden läuft mit Akku. Das ist eigentlich viel mehr als wir brauchen. Zwei Stunden.
Was ist da für das Akkutechnik?
Das ist die Lithium-Polymer-Technik im Moment. Da gibt es also auch verschiedene Probleme, da können wir vielleicht später noch darauf zu sprechen kommen. Also technische Probleme. Aber grundsätzlich funktioniert das Ganze schon. Also wir haben, wie gesagt, den Akku dort drin.
Sag doch mal, was das Problem ist mit dem Akku.
Gut, also zum einen die Lithium-Polymer-Akkus haben im Moment die Eigenschaft, dass sie recht leicht sind und recht klein sind. Das sind die positiven Eigenschaften. Deshalb benutzen wir diesen Akku auch, diesen Akkutyp. Eine negative Eigenschaft ist zum Beispiel, dass er sich nicht unter 0 Grad laden lässt. Zum Beispiel also Temperaturprobleme. Oder bei sehr hohen Temperaturen, wenn das Gerät jetzt in der Sonne steht, bei 50, 60 Grad, die sich vielleicht im Gerät bilden können, altern diese Zellen recht schnell bzw. ist die Selbstentladung recht hoch. So, allerdings ist es eben so, wir sind eigentlich unabhängig von dem Akku. Das heißt, wir können das Gerät allein durch den Dynamo versorgen. Deshalb wiegen diese Probleme jetzt auch nicht so schwer im Moment. Dazu muss man auch sagen, dass die Akkutechnik im Moment massiv in Bewegung ist. Das heißt, allein im letzten halben Jahr gab es drei oder vier verschiedene Revisionen, also nur von denen ich mitbekommen habe, die also Lithium-Polymerzellen betreffen, sodass da also durchaus damit zu rechnen ist, dass sich das Problem ganz alleine löst.
Ja, was man vielleicht noch dazu sagen muss, du sagst ja, du entwickelst das Gerät nicht jetzt komplett alleine.
Also es ist so, wir sind eigentlich ein Team von drei Leuten. Das ist der Chris aus Berlin, der heute nicht hier ist, die Ramona, die auch daran mitarbeitet und eben ich. Man muss dazu sagen, der Chris, der hat uns ganz massiv geholfen bei unserer Webpräsenz. Der stellt uns den Server zur Verfügung und macht ganz viele andere administrative Dinge für uns. Und die Ramona, die macht also auch Webseiten, Webentwicklung und Public Relation, wie man so schön sagt. Also kümmert sich um Messerbesuche und so weiter und um die ganzen Dinge. Und ich mache die Entwicklung, also Software- und Hardwareentwicklung.
Gut, zurück zum Gerät. Also SD-Karte, klar, ist natürlich super, um das Gerät dann vor allem mit so Kartematerial zum Beispiel zu versorgen. USB, wozu da dran?
Genau, also USB ist zum einen da dran, um mit dem Gerät vom normalen PC aus zu kommunizieren. Also man kann auf Gerätedaten zugreifen, man kann zum einen also die Daten, die auf der SD-Karte sind, dort abrufen. Man kann auch das Gerät kalibrieren. Da gibt es also einige Dinge, die kalibrieren werden müssen, zum Beispiel die Gravitationseinheit oder auch Lichtdetektoren und so weiter. Das gehört also auch zu den Features des Geräts. Es hat also auch einen Beschleunigungs-Sensor drin, einen dreiaxigen und hat einen Sensor für die Umgebungshelligkeit, damit das Display sich abdehnen kann. Es ist ein Audioshipsatz drin zum Abspielen und Aufnehmen von Musik bzw. Sprache.
Lass uns noch mal kurz bei dem USB bleiben. Also das Ding agiert dann sozusagen wie eine Festplatte, wenn ich dir einen Rechner anschließe.
Ja, die genaue Implemitierung steht noch nicht fest. Derzeit ist es so, dass man spezielle Software braucht, um auf Gerätedaten zuzugreifen. Wir haben jetzt Linus-Treiber für die USB-Anbindung geschrieben. Von einem normalen Linus-Rechner ist erlaubt, das Gerät erstens die Firmware dort reinzuladen, sprich den Bootloader, damit das Gerät booten kann. Und wie gesagt, in Betriebnahme Schritte zu machen. Test der Hardware und auch Fernsteuerung der Hardware. Das ist der USB-Anschluss. Es ist also ein USB-Device-Anschluss, muss man vielleicht dazu sagen. Die CPU würde auch USB-Host-Anschlüsse unterstützen. Die haben wir allerdings nicht rausgeführt derzeit. Das kann sich vielleicht demnächst ändern.
Mal schauen. Ja, wenn man jetzt halt da noch Geräte anschließt, dann hat man natürlich auch das Problem, dann wieder mit Stromversorgung und so.
Ganz genau, das steht die Unabhängigkeit auf dem Spiel.
Weil du es jetzt schon angesprochen hast, also die Audio-Geschichte, also hat einen Kopfhörerausgang?
Genau, also derzeit hat es einen ganz normalen Kopfhörerausgang. So ist es ein 3,5 mm Klinkenanschluss, der also sicher am Sockel befindet. Einfach, damit theoretisch auch der Kopfhörer am Fahrrad verbleiben kann, auch wenn man das Gerät rauszieht. Also es ist einfach ein mobiler Player für alles, was man sich denken kann, also MP3s, Waves oder was auch immer. Das ist letztendlich eine Softwarefrage. Und gedacht ist es vor allem für eben Musik beim Fahren oder eben Podcasts oder eben vielleicht auch Guided Tours. Das ist die Musikausgabe. Was die Hardware auch kann, ist Musik aufnehmen, sowohl aus einer Mikrofonquelle als auch theoretisch von anderen Quellen. Wobei die Mikrofonquelle natürlich bei der Fahrt auch ganz interessant sein könnte, um beispielsweise Wegdaten, also Dinge, wenn man jetzt streckenabfährt oder auch lockt, einfach aufzusprechen, also einfach ins Mikrofon zu sagen, zu erzählen, ohne anzuhalten, um vielleicht Details zur Strecke einfach zu hinterlegen. Also das OpenStreetMap ist da auch wieder ein Stichwort. Also wenn ich jetzt neue Wege vermesse, kann ich einfach sagen, rechts ist eine Einbahnstraße, links ist ein Briefkasten. Und wenn ich dann wieder bei der Auswertung meiner Daten bin, kann ich ohne, dass ich große Probleme habe, mir wirklich Details über die Strecke damit...
Weil sozusagen im Zeitpunkt, wo man das sagt, einfach quasi die GPS-Koordinate mit Audio dazu gespeichert wird.
So ist es. Also ein GPS-Empfänger ist eingebaut, der die Daten, der in der Lage ist, die Positionsdaten zu liefern, die wir also auch loggen auf SD-Karte und eventuell zur Anzeige bringen. Das ist also auch ein Software-Issue, der im Moment... Wir haben also die Software noch nicht, die die Daten darstellt auf der Karte. Die Software machen wir im Moment komplett selbst für das Gerät. Also vom Boot-Zeltpunkt an, über das grafische User-Interface, über die Test-Software und so weiter. Software ist halt noch nicht End-User-fähig.
Ja klar, das sollte man vielleicht auch nochmal sagen. Wir reden jetzt hier über ein Projekt, das wirklich in Entwicklung ist. Ich habe das jetzt auch mal rausgewählt, hier für Chaosradio Express, um einfach auch mal zu zeigen, was man eben konkret bauen kann, unter Einsatz der aktuellen Technologie und vor allem auch Software. Bevor wir dazu zu dem Software-Teil kommen, vielleicht nochmal der Bildschirm selber. Was ist das? Wie groß ist der?
Es handelt sich um einen 3,5 Zoll TFT-Display, farbig. Wir verbauen dafür, oder im Moment verbauen wir dafür, einen tageslichttauglichen Typ, der also auch recht hell ist, allerdings leider auch recht viel Strom verbraucht. Da gibt es also derzeit noch ein paar Detailprobleme in technischer Art. Eine Idee, die derzeit im Raum steht, ist die Verwendung von OLED-Displays. Die gibt es auch in der Größe, sind noch wesentlich dünner und dementsprechend auch attraktiver für das Gerät. Aber wie gesagt, derzeit haben wir also ein 3,5 Zoll TFT-Display. Ist so, sagen wir mal, wie kann man das vielleicht sagen, vielleicht drei Streichholzschachteln hintereinander gelegt, so von der Größe. Und ja, im Moment, was wir jetzt hier bei dem Prototyp sehen, das ist ein Displaytest. Das ist also was, was dieses Haus noch nie verlassen hat, die Betriebnahme-Software. Ganz nebenbei ein anderes Gerät, was wir hier sehen. Da läuft ein kleines Demo drauf. Da kann man jetzt, wenn man jetzt sieht, das Bedienkonzept noch sich anschauen, wenn das Gerät also nicht im Fahrrad steckt. Wenn das Gerät also nicht im Fahrrad steckt, das heißt, man hat keine Lenkertasten, um das Gerät zu bedienen, stellt sich natürlich die Frage, wie bediene ich das Ganze? Da wir kein Touchscreen haben, gehen wir also den Weg über den Gravitationssensor. Das heißt, wir können das Gerät durch Neigen und Kippen bedienen und können durch ruckartige Bewegungen nach rechts scrollen und ruckartige Bewegungen nach links scrollen oder auch smooth scrollen.
Das ersetzt dann sozusagen die Taste?
Das ersetzt einfach die Taste. Wir haben absolut keine Tasten an dem Gerät. Das war auch ein Ziel. Wir wollten so wenig wie möglich Öffnungen, denn jede Öffnung macht das Gerät anfällig für Feuchtigkeit und geht dann auf Kosten der Robustizität zusammen.
Ja, Helligkeitssensor hast du schon angesprochen, um den Bildschirm entsprechend anzupassen. Das war es aber jetzt sozusagen. Also Audio, GPS, USB, Beschleunigungs-Sensor, Helligkeitssensor, der Bildschirm. Dann sind noch ein paar lustige LEDs da oben eingebaut.
Das sind im Moment drei LEDs, die man da sieht. Die geben also Zustand über den Ladezustand und über den Zustand des Geräts selbst. Was wir auch noch drin haben ist ein Pulsmesser. Das heißt, wir können mit normalen Pulsgurten unsere Herzfrequenz damit loggen. Das ist also auch eine Sache, die man beim Sport machen, die ganz interessant ist. Wie hoch ist mein Puls gerade?
Den schließt man dann an?
Den schließt man, der läuft über Funk. Das heißt, man verwendet diese normalen, ohne Werbung zu machen, Polar-Gurte oder auch Sigma-Gurte. Und die senden periodischen Signal. Und dieses Signal empfangen wir und rechnen daraus die Herzfrequenz.
Was ist denn das Standard hier so?
Leider nicht, es ist leider kein Standard. Es gibt kodierte Pulsgurte und unkodierte Pulsgurte. Und mittlerweile gibt es auch Pulsgurte, die in 2,4 GHz-Band senden. Die können wir im Moment nicht unterstützen. Was wir unterstützen, sind die normalen Bänder, die man für normal erschwinglich Geld kaufen kann.
Das heißt, Training ist auf jeden Fall auch eine ganz klare Stoßrichtung.
Ganz genau.
Professionelles Trainingsunterstützungstool. Der Beschleunigungs-Sensor kann ja sicherlich dabei auch noch zu anderen Sachen eingesetzt werden, als jetzt nur festzustellen, ob man die nach links oder rechts geschüttelt hat, oder?
Zum einen ist es ja so, dass es wirklich motivierend ist, beim Fahren drei Balken zu sehen, die drei Gravitations-, also die drei Achsen, und dann mal eine Kurve zu fahren und sich einfach nur an dem schicken Bild zu erfreuen, wie sich die Balken verändern, wenn man das Fahrrad neigt.
Fahren, bis es die Balken biegen.
Genau. Also das ist natürlich jetzt, sagen wir mal, wirklich macht man noch Spaß. Nee, aber am Ernst, der Gravitationssensor hat natürlich schon noch einen ernsten Hintergrund. Beim Fahren kann der Information über die Strecke liefern. Das heißt, da das Gerät ja selbst mit dem Fahrrad verbunden ist, also fest am Rahmen letztendlich verbunden ist, kriegt natürlich der BICO auch jeden Stoß mit und jede Erschütterung mit. Und wir können diesen Gravitationssensor recht schnell abtasten. Das heißt, wir können dadurch auch eine Analyse machen, über was für eine Straße fahre ich jetzt eigentlich. Ist das Kopfsteinpflaster? Wenn ja, wie groß ist denn der Plattenabstand? Oder vielleicht wie tief sind die Löcher? Gut, wie tief können wir vielleicht nicht sagen, aber wir können sagen, wie groß der Plattenabstand ist. Das ergibt sich aus der Geschwindigkeit und aus der Frequenz, die man herausrechnen kann. Und das ist natürlich wieder auch eine Sache, wie kann ich mit möglichst wenig Aufwand möglichst viel über die gefahrene Strecke sagen. Also der Gravitationssensor kann dabei definitiv einen wesentlichen Beitrag leisten.
Ist denn das Gerät auch in der Lage, die Idee kommt mir jetzt nur gerade, so etwas wie Steigungen in irgendeiner Form dabei herauszulesen, ist das machbar?
Steigung ist definitiv auch ein Punkt. Bei der Steigungsermittlung hat man natürlich zwei Probleme. Zum einen beschleunige ich, also ich bremse ab und fahre schneller beim Fahren. Und das sind natürlich Dinge, die der Beschleunigungssensor auch als Beschleunigung mitbekommt. Und wenn ich in eine Steigung fahre, ist das letztendlich auch nichts anderes als eine Beschleunigung. Das heißt, kurz und gut gesagt, das Bremsen oder Beschleunigen des Fahrrads auf gerader Strecke beeinflusst natürlich auch die Steigungsmessung. Man kann natürlich durch Mittelungen schon ziemlich exakt sagen, in welchem Winkel fahre ich jetzt den Berg hinauf. Zum Beispiel, also diese Information kann der Beschleunigungsmesser liefern.
Kann er sie auch liefern, sodass man sich auch sicher ist, dass das jetzt wirklich stattfindet?
Das kann man... Das hängt davon ab, wie man die Daten aufbereitet. Der Geschwindigkeitsmesser hat ja eine exakte Information, wie schnell fahre ich denn. Also bekommt auch der Geschwindigkeitsmesser, also spricht der Name Dynamo mit, bremse ich gerade ab oder nicht? Das heißt, diese Information liegt vor und entsprechend mathematischen Regeln kann ich dann aus der Steigungsinformation auch bzw. aus der Beschleunigungsinformation auch die Steigung herausrechnen. Das ist natürlich eine Sache, die wir im Moment nicht implementiert haben. Im Moment zeigt das Gerät blind die Steigung an, in welchem Winkel man das Gerät hält. Aber die Kopplung mit dem Geschwindigkeitssensor, der sehr präzise ist, kann dafür helfen, eine exakte Steigungsmessung zu machen.
Das ist natürlich super interessant, weil man dann erstmal die Trainingsergebnisse, wie schnell bin ich gefahren, auch konkret in Relation setzen kann zu den Gegebenheiten auf der Straße. Füffig.
Zu der Steigung muss man noch einen Punkt sagen.
Warte mal, eine Frage noch. Was du jetzt nur in dem Wire erwähnt hast, also Geschwindigkeit, dann misst das Ding jetzt nicht über GPS, sondern auch über den Nabendynamo.
Also Geschwindigkeit wird auch über GPS gemessen, aber wahrscheinlich nicht wirklich verwertet. Denn GPS liefert einfach nur einen Puls pro Sekunde, bei guten Geräten 5 Puls pro Sekunde. Der Nabendynamo, je nachdem, was man für ein Modell hat, bietet da wesentlich mehr Information. Das heißt, gehe ich jetzt von einem recht guten Nabendynamo aus, der liefert 26 Pulse pro Radumdrehung. Das heißt, ich habe also auch recht häufige Updates. Das heißt, ich habe sehr präzise, dass das Rad absolut keinen Schlupf hat. Das heißt, der Dynamo befindet sich im Vorderrad, was normalerweise immer eine feste Verbindung zum Untergrund hat. Das heißt, wir haben keinen Schlupf, wie man das vielleicht bei anderen Dynamos hat. Oder auch bei normalen Geschwindigkeitsabnehmern, die einen Puls pro Umdrehung liefern, habe ich auch einen Schlupf. Man ist sich dessen gar nicht bewusst. Aber wenn die Dinger zum Beispiel über Funk verbunden sind, dann habe ich da auch Empfangsausfälle und ich habe Störungen von irgendwelchen Türöffnern, die da Störungen verursachen. Also man kann dazu sagen, die Geschwindigkeit ist absolut präzise. Wir haben Messungen gemacht bis auf 0,1. Also wir sind von einer Umdrehung, von einer Umdrehung messen wir auf 20 cm genau. Das heißt, wenn ich das Vorderrad um 20 cm drehe, bekomme ich schon zwei Pulse. Das ist also schon ziemlich exakt.
Ist denn diese Anschlussgeschichte bei den Nabendynamos auch in irgendeiner Form standardisiert oder gibt es da auch solche und solche?
Also der Anschluss ist standardisiert. Das befindet normalerweise mit solchen normalen Flachsteckern statt. Was nicht standardisiert ist, ist die Anzahl der Pole. Also sprich, gute Dynamos wie der SON, da mache ich gerne Werbung, weil das eine ganz kleine Firma ist, die wirklich sympathisch ist, die liefern 26 Pole, 26 Pulse. Es gibt billigere Modelle, die liefern nur 10 oder 6 Pulse.
Und das müsste man dann sozusagen konfigurieren?
Das muss man dem Gerät einmal sagen. Es wird im Gerät abgelegt, genau wie der Radumfang, der ist natürlich auch eine variable, die bei jedem Rad unterschiedlich ist, aber ansonsten reicht das aus. Also wenn ich die beiden Informationen habe, dann habe ich eine perfekte Geschwindigkeitsmessung.
Du hast das ja... Wolltest du noch was hinzufügen?
Kurz zu der Steigungsgeschichte war noch ein Punkt. Also das ist so, die Hardware verfügt über einen Höhen-Sensor auch. Das heißt, der ist im Moment bei unseren Prototypen nicht bestückt, ist aber definitiv in der Schaltung vorgesehen.
Was für einen Höhen-Sensor?
Ein barometrischer Höhen-Sensor, das heißt im Endeffekt ein Messer des Umgebungsdrucks. Also ein Sensor für den Umgebungsdruck, der muss natürlich auch kalibriert werden, so wie das bei allen Höhen-Sensoren so ist. Also man muss ihm irgendwann mal sagen, ich bin bei Höhe sowieso. Wobei die Idee natürlich da besteht, dass man eine recht genaue Höhe oder... Was heißt genau? Man kriegt über GPS ja auch eine Höheninformation, die eben nicht genau ist, aber man kann natürlich gut mitteln. Das heißt, wenn das Gerät jetzt an irgendeiner Stelle ziemlich lange steht, also abgestellt ist, kriegt er entsprechend viele Höheninformationen, die dann sich um plus, minus 10 Meter unterscheiden bei den GPS-Informationen. Und diese Information könnte man nutzen, um den barometrischen Höhen-Sensor zu kalibrieren. Das ist natürlich auch Software, die im Moment noch nicht existiert, aber das ist so vorgesehen.
Ja, ich wollte nochmal kurz zurück zu diesem Anmeldungsszenario, was du jetzt schon ein, zwei Mal erwähnt hast. Und im vorletzten Podcast, hier bei CRE, war ja auch OpenStreetMap schon das Thema. Da kamen Fahrräder auch ganz klar schon zum Einsatz, beziehungsweise zur Sprache. Und scheint auch so, dass die Fahrradgemeinde auch noch eine ganz spezielle Affinität hat zu dem OpenStreetMap, weil natürlich Kartennaterial heutzutage sehr autofahrerfreundlich ist und vielleicht auch touristenfreundlich, aber beileibe nicht fahrradfreundlich ist. Insofern bietet sich das natürlich anders zu integrieren. Da hast du schon ein paar Ideen genannt, wie man das machen kann. Einerseits halt quasi so als Endanwender, sag ich mal, dass man eben einfach die Karten verwendet, weil das erlaubt ja die Lizenz und der Bildschirm wiederum hier, erlaubt ja dann auch eine relativ gute Darstellung gepaart mit GPS. Und das andere ist eben das Gerät als Erfassungssystem zu verwenden.
Genau, also das...
Können wir das noch mal kurz zusammenfassen? Also man kann GPS-Tracks damit machen, ganz klar. Und ist denn diese Idee mit der Audio-Annotation jetzt so die einzige Ansatz, die ihr da verfolgt oder für möglich haltet, oder gibt es da noch andere Optionen?
Na ja, also man muss ja dazu sagen, dass das Fahrrad so häufig von Street-Mappern akquiriert wird, hat ja ganz klar den Hintergrund, dass es einfach das ideale Vorbewegungsmittel ist, zum Erkunden neuer Strecken. Man hat dann eine Geschwindigkeit, die schneller ist als beim Laufen, aber man ist immer noch langsamer als beim Autofahren, deshalb man sieht auch noch was, man sieht auch noch alle Details, man sieht auch Bordsteinkanten und man sieht auch vielleicht wirklich Briefkästen oder Einbahnstraßen. Gut, die sieht man beim Autofahren vielleicht auch hoffentlich. Das ist natürlich ein Ziel des Gerätes, für den versierten Streetmapper auch wirklich das perfekte Eingabegerät zu sein. Das heißt, wenn man es wirklich nochmal zusammenfasst, ich muss nicht mehr anhalten, um Informationen über meinen aktuellen Ort oder die aktuelle Position zu hinterlegen, sprich diese Information kann ich in meinem Mikrofon sprechen, was ich über den Lenkertaster einschalte, das heißt, das hält mich auch überhaupt nicht vom Fahren ab, was ja auch sicherheitsrelevant ist. Zum anderen haben wir eine exakte Geschwindigkeit, womit ich Analysen machen kann, wie schnell kann ich denn überhaupt fahren an der Strecke. Ist das vielleicht eine Strecke, wo ich jetzt wirklich richtig gut Stoff geben kann, weil das vielleicht ein Backup ist oder so? Solche Sachen ist vielleicht eine Information. Ansonsten habe ich natürlich die Position, wo ich mich befinde. Ich sehe sogar, ob es dort hell oder dunkel ist, oder ob es dort warm oder kalt ist. Also der barometrische Höhen-Sensor bringt eine implizite Temperaturmessung mit, weil die Temperatur gebraucht wird zum Kompensieren der Ergebnisse von dem Sensor. Das heißt, die Temperatur haben wir auch zur Verfügung im Gerät.
Das ist dann auch nach außen geführt, oder ist das dann auch die Gesamtgerätetemperatur?
Ja, das ist zunächst mal die Gesamtgerätetemperatur. Das ist schon richtig.
Einschließlich der Prozessorwärme.
Wobei die nicht so hoch ist. Er ist natürlich passiv gekühlt, um keinen falschen Eindruck zu erwecken. Kommen wir vielleicht gleich noch dazu, was dabei verbaut ist im Detail. Aber nochmal auf die Streetmapping-Geschichte zurückzukommen. Man hat durch die Verwendung des Bicos, wenn er denn soweit ist, die Vorteile, dass man bei der Fahrt Information hinterlassen und loggen kann und dabei auch auf präzise Daten zurückgreifen kann.
Aber wie stellst du dir das vor mit dem Audio? Ich meine, beim OpenStreetMap sieht es ja so aus, dass man sich dann normalerweise diesen Track als Textfile nimmt und irgendwie hochlädt und dann in so einem Editor bearbeitet. Der ist ja quasi auf Audio nicht vorbereitet. Brauchte man dann noch einen speziellen Editor, der das auch unterstützt?
Gut, das ist die Frage der Nachbearbeitung. Das heißt, man fährt halt diesen Track und letztendlich gibt es ja schon die Art des Aufarbeitens der Daten. Das heißt, man schickt das Textfile ja nicht ungesehen weg, sondern man setzt sich danach hin und analysiert die Daten und hat dann die Möglichkeit mit der Hilfe des Audiofiles, der man ja die Position zu ordnen kann. Also ist ja jeden Tag, den ich also quasi mache, kann ich ja eine Position zuordnen und kann dann beim Aufbereiten meiner Daten dann noch zusätzliche Informationen in dem Editor, den es auch jetzt schon gibt, im Übrigen hinzufügen. Also das Audio dient einfach nur als Merkhilfe für einen selbst.
Das ist klar, aber jetzt komme ich gerade drauf. Man kann ja in dem Moment nicht das Audiofile, das muss man ja nicht auf den Rechner rüber kopieren, sondern das kann man auf dem OpenBICO belassen, der das dann abspielt und dann gleichzeitig diese Koordinate dann mit einblendet und dann vielleicht auch die Karte noch. Ich meine, das heißt, wie ordnest du das jetzt zu? Weil man muss ja wissen, wo war ich denn jetzt wirklich in dem Bereich.
Aber das ist noch, glaube ich, ein in Detail ungelöstes Problem.
Aber es ist natürlich klar, dass jetzt einfach Audio eine super Eingabeform wäre, weil man sich ja dann nicht weiß, woran du da gedacht hast im Audioeingang. Mir würde dann einfach diese ganz normale Telefon-Headsets da einfallen, mit eingebauten Mikrofonen. Das heißt, wie so ein Kopfhörer. Man hat da jetzt nicht noch mal ein extra Mikrofon vorne dran, sondern das klebt dann irgendwie an der Brust.
Genau, oder eben diese Kragen-Mikrofone, die es gibt. Es gibt auch Kehlkopf-Mikrofone mittlerweile, die dann windunempfindlich sind und so weiter. Also es gibt da wirklich schon...
Das Problem gibt es ja auch noch.
Ja, genau. Also es gibt da schon Möglichkeiten, auch, sagen wir mal, unauffällig. Also es muss nicht sein, dass ich jetzt mit einem riesen Headset durch die Gegend fahre, aber wenn ich jetzt wirklich nur das Mikrofon benutze, reicht eben auch ein Kragenmikrofon aus. Und behindert einen entsprechend auch nicht.
Ja, dann schauen wir doch mal rein in das Gerät. Was steckt denn da nun eigentlich drin in der ganzen Elektronik?
Gut, also derzeit ist es so... Also ich spreche jetzt wirklich vom jetzigen Prototypen-Stadium. Es handelt sich um zwei CPUs, die also in dem Gerät ihren Dienst verrichten. Zum einen eine recht kleine CPU, ein Atmega88 ist das, also ein 8-Bit-Prozessor.
Ein Atmel-Prozessor.
Genau, der die ganze Sensorik macht, das heißt, der kümmert sich um alle Echtzeitbelange im Gerät. Echtzeitbelange sind zum Beispiel die Pulsfrequenz, sind die Taster am Lenkrad, sind die Taster am Lenker, beziehungsweise die Geschwindigkeitsinformation des Dynamos. Und zusätzlich kümmert er sich um die Laderegelung der Akkumulatoren beziehungsweise des Akkus. Dann haben wir einen zweiten Prozessor, der Hauptprozessor, das ist ein ARM 9, eine ARM 9 CPU mit 200 MIPS, also 200 Millionen Befehler pro Sekunde, die sie ausführen kann. Die kümmert sich um die ganzen Belange, die auf höherer Ebene ablaufen, also Display, GPS, SD-Karte, Flash und so weiter. Wir haben 128 MB RAM drin, das ist durchaus üppig für so ein kleines mobiles Gerät. Das lässt also genügend Spielraum für Ideen. Zusätzlich haben wir einen Audio-Ship-Satz, der in der Lage ist, Daten aufzunehmen und auch gleichzeitig abzuspielen. Also Full Duplex. Und was haben wir noch? Das ist im Prinzip das Gerät in groben Zügen. Das Ganze liegt also vor, in einer etwas größer als Zigarettenschachtel größeren Platine. Also die Platine ist etwas größer als eine Zigarettenschachtel, kann man vielleicht ganz gut vergleichen. Dicht gedrängt. Dicht gedrängt, ja. Das ist also voll, das Teil. Also gut, es ist einseitig bestückt, kann man vielleicht noch dazu sagen. Das hat einfach Gründe, die jetzt mechanischer Natur sind. Also wir haben das Problem, was wir halt haben, wir haben natürlich alle Probleme, die man hat im Bezug auf solche, auf eine Entwicklung von so mobilen Geräten. Also wir haben die Gehäuseproblematik, die Mechanik, wir müssen Zeichnungen machen für die Gehäuse und müssen die dann auch machen lassen. Und das Ganze muss dann auch passen. Also die Platinen müssen nach Möglichkeit dort reinpassen. Also die mechanischen Probleme sind definitiv ein wesentlicher Knackpunkt oder ein wesentliches Problem bei dem Ganzen für uns. Ansonsten von der Elektronik her, was sich also auch noch darauf befindet, ist die ganze Stromversorgungsgeschichte. Die wird in der nächsten Version wahrscheinlich auf einer eigenen Platine stattfinden mit aktiven Gleichrichtern, damit man also die Strom, also das, was vom Dynamo erzeugt wird, auch möglichst effektiv ohne Verlust dem System zuführen kann. Und der aktive Gleichrichter trägt auch wesentlich dazu bei, dass das Gerät nicht warm wird. Man muss dazu sagen, bei solchen Nabendynamos habe ich einen recht großen Bereich von Spannung, die so ein Dynamo erzeugt. Das können durchaus mal 20, 30 Volt sein, wenn das System unbelastet ist, also dass der Bico vielleicht schläft oder vielleicht eben wenig Strom braucht. Und das geht eben runter. Je nachdem, wie viel man letztendlich an Leistung umsetzt, bricht die Spannung entsprechend ein. Das heißt, man braucht schon einen Weg, um die Energie möglichst effizient zu nutzen. Und das machen wir in Form von aktiven Gleichrichtern und verschiedenen Schaltreglern. Also das Power-Concept ist halt auch ein wesentlicher Punkt.
So, das ist also die Hardware. Was läuft denn nun auf diesen Prozessoren für eine Software? Welches Betriebssystem kommt hier zum Einsatz?
Also grundsätzlich die Demo-Version oder die Prototypen, die wir jetzt hier haben, da läuft erstmal kein Betriebssystem im herkömmlichen Sinne drauf. Also zunächst mal haben wir einen Bootloader, also ein Programm, was sofort nach dem Einschalten, nach dem Reset des Systems greift. Dieser Bootloader ist also auch von uns entwickelt. Er erwartet eine SD-Karte im Slot und sucht dort drauf bestimmte Dateien. Und wenn die gefunden werden, dann werden die einfach ausgeführt. Und diese Dateien sind prozessorabhängige Binärfiles. Also es sind keine Shared Libraries oder keine Exe-Files oder keine Elf-Binaries oder sowas, sondern es ist wirklich nativer Code. Der wird direkt ins Speicher geladen und dort ausgeführt. Und dieser Code kann jetzt entweder sein ein Second-Stage-Loader, der zum Beispiel Linux lädt und ausführt oder eben auch ein eigener kleiner Kern, so wie hier in diesem Demo. Also wir haben jetzt hier einen eigenen Kern gemacht, der die Eigenschaft hat, dass er sehr, sehr, sehr schnell bootet. Also wir liegen hier weit unter drei Sekunden Startzeit von dem Gesamtsystem. Und er ist natürlich perfekt auf die Hardware zugeschnitten, also läuft auch nur auf dieser Hardware, muss man dazu sagen. Und hat aber die Eigenschaft, dass er alle Peripherieelemente jetzt schon unterstützt. Also wir können zugreifen auf die Geschwindigkeit, auf die Beschleunigungsdaten usw. Also wir haben die komplette Peripherie softwaremäßig unterstützt. Alternativ haben wir den Linus-Könnel portiert, dahingehend, dass er auf der Architektur läuft. Auf der Armarchitektur liefert er schon vorher, aber wir haben also die Anpassung gemacht, die dazu führen, dass das Ding also auch bootet auf dem BICO.
Wieso? Hat er vorher nicht gebootet?
Na ja gut, also der Kernel braucht gewisse Anpassungen an die Peripherie, an die Hardware. Also er muss wissen, wie viel Speicher er hat, und er muss wissen, wo ist das Display eingeblendet, in welchem Adressbereich und solche Dinge. Und der Linux-Kernel bootet ja auch nicht ohne Linux-Loader. Also das heißt, auch der Bootloader muss in der Lage sein, die Linux-Kernel zu laden, das Router-Teilsystem vorzubereiten, an die richtige Stelle zu relocieren und so weiter. Das ist das, was ich jetzt mit Linux-Port meine in dem Sinne. Also der Kernel ist natürlich fertig, der funktioniert. Also der startet jetzt hoch und hat Zugriff auf die SD-Karte. Und der kann auch das Display ansteuern, also man sieht einen kleinen Pinguin auf dem Display, das funktioniert. Und man kann sich über Telnet auf das Gerät einloggen, das macht man über USB, also sprich, der USB-Device-Port läuft im Moment unter Linux in einer Netzwerk-Immulation. Das heißt, wenn man den BICO an den PC dransteckt, dann verhält er sich wie eine Netzwerkkarte. Das heißt, ich kann mich per Telnet auf das Gerät einloggen und kann per FTP Daten übertragen und das funktioniert alles. Das ist das Linux-Development-Environment, und das haben wir letztendlich, ja, das funktioniert. Wobei, wie gesagt, Linux braucht bei dem BICO im Moment um die 10, 12, 20 Sekunden zum Starten. Das ist halt recht lang. Und wir präferieren eigentlich ein System, wo wir möglichst schnell booten und wo wir möglichst to the point genau das erreichen, was wir wollen und nicht alles haben und dann geht die Hälfte davon nicht.
Du hast gesagt, du hast einen eigenen Kernel entwickelt. Also läuft da jetzt sozusagen auch die Software, die hier die bunten Bilder anzeigt, die ich hier gerade sehe?
Genau, also der eigene Kernel, der macht letztendlich, kümmert sich um die Belange der Speilverwaltung, um die Belange des Datalsystems und um die Belange des Displays und so weiter, also die ganze Peripherie. Und ein grundlegendes Scheduling haben wir auch, das heißt, wir können mehrere Prozesse parallel laufen lassen, wobei wir davon noch keinen Gebrauch machen, weil der Fahrradcomputer erstmal eine Anwendung ist und wir haben bis jetzt noch keinen parallel laufenden Audio Player oder so. Das wird alles auf uns zukommen. Wie gesagt, der hat die Eigenschaft, dass er recht schnell bootet, das heißt, er macht nur wirklich das, was er auch wirklich machen muss. Und eine andere Eigenschaft ist, dass er also komplett in C++ implementiert ist. Also es gibt nur C++ und Assembler. Also es gibt gewisse Software-Strukturen, die dort einfach eingehalten sind und es gibt auch gewisse Designregeln, die dort umgesetzt sind.
Also, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, Linux läuft drauf, aber eigentlich ist das nicht die eigentliche Plattform, die ihr haben wollt, um die Anwendung laufen zu lassen?
Gut, also wir...
Oder seid ihr da noch nicht entschieden?
Wir sind noch nicht entschieden, um es vielleicht ganz klar zu sagen.
Ist das jetzt nur das Problem, dass es so langsam bootet?
Nö, also das langsam booten ist vielleicht ein Punkt. Also das ist für uns erstmal auch eine Spielwiese, dieses Gerät. Also wir haben das jetzt gebaut und haben letztendlich hier ein System, wo man also auch mal Dinge ausprobieren kann, die man vielleicht beim PC so nicht ausprobiert oder nicht mehr ausprobiert, weil sie einfach schon zu komplex sind. Also warum nicht mal schnell einen Körner schreiben? Warum sollte man das nicht ausprobieren?
Ja, klar, ich wollte hier auch nicht davon abhalten. So ist natürlich jetzt nicht so, dass jetzt jeder Mann, der sich mit Hardware-Entwicklung auskennt, auch gleich noch einen passenden Körner dazu entwickeln möchte oder kann.
Die Sache ist halt, wir wollen nicht vorschreiben, was man darauf benutzt, also der Linus-Körner ist portiert. Und wenn die Rahmenbedingungen das erlauben, sinnvoll darauf einzusetzen, why not? Dann ist das eine gute Sache. Für Linus gibt es halt eine Menge guter Programme. Also alles, was man so im Linus-Umfeld hat, funktioniert meist recht gut. Und das wäre natürlich eine Schande, das nicht zu nutzen. Also insofern wollen wir auch, dass Linus auf diesem Gerät läuft. Und vielleicht gibt es ja neben der Anwendung als Fahrradcomputer noch andere Anwendungen, die man mit ähnlicher Sensorik sinnvoll gestalten kann.
Hast du da schon Ideen, oder ist das jetzt nur so ins Blaue hinein?
Das ist erst mal ins Blaue hinein, aber die Hardware, muss man sagen, das handelt sich ja um ein Mikrorechnersystem mit verschiedenen CPUs und mit Displayern und so weiter. Die Ideen müssen ja jetzt noch nicht kommen, was man damit macht, aber die kommen.
Nein, klar, ich freue mich, falls dir schon was gekommen ist, dann hätte ich das jetzt gerne gehört.
Also erstmal sind wir ganz gut ausgelassen mit dem Fahrradcomputer.
Aber gibt es denn jetzt außer Linux keine anderen Betriebssysteme, die jetzt für eure Zwecke da... Ich meine, es gibt ja auch noch kleine Mini-Könnel-Systeme, die durchaus schneller booten und jetzt nicht...
Genau, die gibt es, ja. Also das ist...
Hast du da mal was ausprobiert?
Muss ich sagen, nein, habe ich nicht ausprobiert, weil ich die auch nicht kennen im Detail. Ich kenne zum Beispiel den Fiasco-Könnel, ein ganz interessantes Projekt, auch ein in C++ implementierter Betriebssystem-Kern. Es gibt auch andere Körner, das ist schon richtig, aber wir müssen natürlich jetzt gucken, oder wir haben jetzt erstmal das gemacht, was wir auch können, also das, was in unserer Macht steht. Da das ja eine offene Hardware ist, steht das dann anderen auch frei, andere Sachen zu probieren. Vielleicht gibt es auch wirklich Körner, die perfekt matchen auf das, was wir wollen. Wir wollen natürlich keinen kommerziellen Körner. Das ist eigentlich die Einschränkung, die wir machen. Die wir zumindest für uns machen.
Vielleicht nochmal kurz, noch nicht gleich weg von dieser Anwendungsgeschichte. Das ist natürlich auch immer so eine Sache, wenn man etwas als Open gekennzeichnet hat, aber jetzt nicht von vornherein sagt, das ist jetzt eine komplett freie Entwicklung. Dann stellt sich natürlich die Frage, ob sich das jetzt irgendwie auf die Software auswirkt. Eigentlich ja nicht. Ihr bietet ja im Prinzip eine Plattform an, auf der man dann komplett frei entwickeln kann. Das ist ja uneingeschränkt. Dir geht es jetzt sozusagen nur um die eigentliche Hardware selbst, die an der Stelle erstmal jetzt eure Arbeit ist.
Genau, also bei der Hardware stellt sich ja schon die Frage, also Software lädt man einfach runter, das ist überhaupt kein Problem. Und die werden wir auch komplett ins Netz stellen. Also da wird es keine Einschränkungen geben. Aber bei der Hardware stellt sich ja die Frage, wie kommt der User an die Hardware und wer produziert die Hardware? Und diese Probleme sind definitiv noch ungelöst im Moment. Es ist klar, was wir nicht machen wollen, ist, dass wir das Projekt von vornherein zum Ausschlachten zur Verfügung stellen, dass andere Hersteller, die jetzt vielleicht kommerzielle Interessen haben, das Gerät uns wegnehmen. Das wollen wir halt vermeiden. Aber wir sind da absolut offen für Vorschläge. Das heißt, wir haben da durchaus ein Gehör für Leute, die sagen, so oder so könnte er das machen. Das wäre eine Idee, das vielleicht umzusetzen.
Und die gute Ideen haben, wohin man das noch tragen könnte, für welche Anwendung das doch noch teilt. Was mir jetzt so aus dem Stand natürlich einfallen würde, ist, warum sich nur auf Fahrräder beschränken. Motorräder haben natürlich ähnliche Bedürfnisse.
So ist es. Also das ist definitiv auf einer...
Ich weiß nicht, wie das so mit Nabendynamos aussieht bei...
Gut, da habe ich insofern besser, als dass ich da eine wirklich gesicherte Sturmversorgung habe beim Motorrad. Stellt sich allein die Frage der Geschwindigkeitsabnahme. Wobei ich beim Motorrad ja auch in anderen Geschwindigkeitsdimensionen arbeite, wo ich vielleicht auch mit der GPS-Genauigkeit ganz gut leben kann, muss man sich einfach fragen. Ansonsten gibt es natürlich die Möglichkeit...
Hast du da natürlich so Tunnelproblematiken?
Genau, die Problematik gibt es. Ansonsten gibt es beim Motorrad auch Geschwindigkeitsabnehmer, die man adaptieren kann, mit Sicherheit. Also die verfügen ja schon über elektronische Tachos mittlerweile.
Ich frage, ob man da so ohne weiteres rankommt.
Naja, das muss man gucken.
Oder man ballert sich halt irgendwie so ein externes mit Magneten noch mal ein externes Teil dran.
So nur tut es jeder normale Geschwindigkeitssensor von dem Fahrradmarkt auch üblich sind.
Oder so, was weiß ich, Boote?
Genau, also Boote wäre auch, warum nicht? Also im Endeffekt ist es ein mobiles Device, was Outdoor-tauglich ist und...
Rasenmäher!
Genau, das ist dann Anwendung für GPS-Tracking.
Habe ich auch wirklich alles gemäht. Das ist in der Tat so ein Punkt. Ja, bezüglich der Beteiligung. Also wenn man sich jetzt beteiligen will und einen Einblick nehmen will, wo schaut man denn dann eigentlich hin? Was habt ihr denn für Ressourcen bereits im Netz?
Also wir haben unsere offizielle Webseite, also obico.de, bietet zumindest mal einen Überblick von dem, was wir im Moment so machen. Und bietet auch einen Überblick von dem, wie die Hardware ungefähr aussieht. Also man sieht da ein, zwei Bilder von unseren letzten Messen besuchen und auch wer wir sind und was wir machen und auch wie man uns erreichen kann. Also wir haben eine Mehradresse, diese info.obico.de, die dort auch steht. Dort kann man hinschreiben als jemand, der sich für das Projekt interessiert, sei es als Anwender, der Anregungen hat oder auch als Entwickler, der jetzt ganz stark darauf brennt, mitzumachen und vielleicht die eine oder andere Idee hat, wie kann ich Akkus perfekt laden unter 0°C oder welche Akkotypen habe ich da im Sinn. Wir hatten zum Beispiel eine Mail bekommen von jemand, der eine Arktis-Reise mit dem Gerät machen möchte. Und jetzt ganz klar das Problem hat, dass man es unter 0°C nicht laden kann. Da gibt es dann also andere Akkutechnologien, die da durchaus in Frage kommen.
Oder Klimawandel abwarten.
Oder Klimawandel abwarten. Also einfach die Reise verschieben. Es gibt also schon wirklich interessantes Feedback, was wir bis jetzt erhalten haben. Und wir sind auch sehr glücklich darüber, dass wir da Leute haben, die sich dafür interessieren. Und wie gesagt, wenn jetzt...
Gibt es da auch schon eine Mailing-Liste zum Beispiel?
Die Mailing-Liste sind wir gerade im Einrichten. Wir haben ein Projekt bei SourceForge angemeldet, aber die ist gerade im Bau. Wir sind gerade im Aufbau. Und werden dann letztendlich allen Leuten, die uns geschrieben haben, auch eine Mail mitteilen, dass diese Mailing-Liste jetzt existent ist. Das können wir auf unserer Webseite, wenn wir uns auch hinterlassen.
Könnte also auch schon sein, dass zum Zeitpunkt der Veröffentlichung dieses Podcast, diese Mailing-Liste bereits existiert. Dann werde ich das auf jeden Fall auch in den Links noch erwähnen. Was haben wir vergessen? Also, meine, was was bietet denn sozusagen noch die Zukunft? Was habt ihr denn noch so für... Ich meine, wir haben jetzt im Prinzip schon über eine ganze Menge Anwendungsszenarios gesprochen, nicht nur die jetzt konkret gewünscht sind, sondern die ja theoretisch auch möglich sind. Gibt es denn noch irgendetwas, was ihr explizit was ich denke, sozusagen schon im Kopf habt, aber die jetzt mit der derzeitigen Hardware so noch nicht benutzt werden kann, aber wo vielleicht eine zukünftige Entwicklung hingehen könnte?
Also was wirklich unser oberstes Designziel eigentlich ist, das letztendliche Ziel soll sein, dass der Entwickler oder der Interessierte die Möglichkeit hat, Software auf seinem Fahrrad zu spielen und sich damit zu bereichern beim Fahren, egal welche Anwendungen er da im Sinn hat. Wenn er sich die Fourier transformierte Musik anschauen will auf dem Display beim Fahren, dann soll er das tun können und dafür wollen wir eben die Plattform schaffen. Könnte ja ganz motivierend sein. Wenn jemand aufgrund seines Herzschlags die Musik gepitcht haben will, um vielleicht 30 Prozent mehr Leistung zu erreichen, dann möge er das tun mit dem Gerät. Das ist das, wo es hingehen soll. Im Moment sind wir von der Hardware-Entwicklung eben noch nicht hundertprozentig fertig. Wir haben einfach noch gewisse Probleme. Gerade die Akkuladerei ist eben noch ein Punkt, der jetzt mehr oder weniger offen ist. Wir haben etwas, was funktioniert, aber es ist eben noch nicht so perfekt, wie wir es haben wollen. Das Display ist auch noch ein Punkt. Wenn die Sonne ganz doll drauf strahlt, sehen wir im Prinzip auch nichts mehr. Das heißt, wir wollen dort schon noch am Display was ändern.
Gibt es da nicht so Methoden mit selbst reflektierenden Bildschirmen, die das Licht noch explizit verstärken?
Es gibt transplektive Displays. Das haben wir auch evaluiert, also getestet. Die haben wieder den Nachteil, dass die bei normaler Helligkeit, wenn die Sonne nicht draufkreischt, dass man dann wieder Probleme kriegt, die abzulesen. Es gibt eigentlich nicht das optimale Display. Es gibt immer Bereiche, wo die dann irgendwie schlecht sind. Das ist so unsere Erfahrung. Eine Ausnahme könnten die OLED-Displays sein, die mittlerweile auch entsprechend lange halten. Das heißt, die kommen durchaus in Betracht. Die liegen also von der Lebensdauer mittlerweile schon durchaus da, wo man bei normalen TFT-Displays auch ist. Das ist aber neu und das gibt es eigentlich auch noch nicht so lange. Die haben wir also noch nicht in den Größen. Also 3,5 Zoll ist schon recht groß für ein OLED-Display. Die gibt es noch nicht so lange, als dass wir das jetzt schon fertig haben könnten. Das ist also wirklich eine Sache, die jetzt noch in die Zukunft geht. Ansonsten, ja, was wir also wollen, ist dann eine aktive Community für das Teil. Und die Lösung, wie wir das nachher irgendwie an den Mann bringen. Diese Informationen, die haben wir bis jetzt noch nicht. Also das muss man einfach sagen. Also wenn es jemanden gibt, der gute Ideen hat, einfach uns anschreiben.
Mich erinnert das Projekt jetzt auch sehr an ein anderes Projekt, was ich hier vor ein paar Sendungen schon vorgestellt habe. Die Quadrocopter-Systeme, die im Prinzip auch mit ähnlichen Einschränkungen die Software veröffentlichen und die Hardware veröffentlichen, sich da kommerzielle Nutzung vorbehalten, aber sich ja im Prinzip auch eine eigene Community aufgebaut haben von Leuten, die das eben privat vor allem zur Anwendung bringen wollen oder auch teilweise kommerziell, aber damit entsprechenden Absprachen. Ich denke, das ist hier so ein bisschen ähnlich gelagert.
Also wir wollen schon, dass der normale Anwender, also wenn man jetzt kein Entwickler ist und wir sind auf dem Stand, also wenn wir auf dem Stand sind, dass die Software so weit die Grundfunktionalität leistet, dann soll sich ein normaler Mensch, der das Ding benutzen möchte, auch kaufen können. Das ist schon das Ziel. Und da denke ich, gibt es auch kein Problem mit. Er hat dann auch alle Informationen, die der Entwickler auch hat. Aber er hat letztendlich dann einfach das Gerät mit den Features, die es hat und muss dafür ja nicht Software entwickeln. Aber das wollen wir schon auch erlauben. Also wir wollen schon haben, dass man das Gerät auch kaufen kann in einer oder anderen Form.
Sonst noch irgendwelche Ausblicke, was ihr euch so wünscht? Technologische Fortschritte, die mal stattfinden könnten, außer den Akkus und den Bildschirmen.
Naja, das reicht eigentlich. Das reicht eigentlich.
Ja, gut, dann haben wir es, oder? Super, Peer. Ich finde, das ist ein schickes Device. Also ich finde, das macht wirklich auch schwer was her so. Also vor allem finde ich, optisch erfüllt es euren Wunsch, solide daherzukommen, definitiv. Das ist schön gebürstet und metalloid und...
Relaxiert ist es noch nicht.
Auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall eine Augenweide am Fahrrad oder am Boot oder auf dem Bagger oder auf dem Rasenmäher oder was auch immer ihr so an mobilen Geräten so habt, wo ihr dann schon immer mal die Geschwindigkeit messen wolltet oder die Vibrationen messen. Ich bedanke mich, Peer, für die Ausführungen über euer Projekt.
Hat Spaß gemacht.
Und wer Lust hat, vielleicht daran teilzunehmen oder jetzt im Laufe des Gesprächs auch schon eine tolle Idee bekommen hat, was man damit vielleicht auch noch machen könnte, oder sich in irgendeiner Form an der Entwicklung beteiligen möchte, soll nachschlagen. www.obico.de, richtig? Ansonsten könnt ihr auch Fragen konkret stellen und vor allem Kommentare abgeben zu dieser Sendung, wie immer, bei blog.chaosradio.ccc.de. Der Peer wird da sicherlich auch mitlesen. Und ja, das war's. Wieder mal. Ich bedanke mich nochmal. Und ja, bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.